[Music]
so I try watching the remake of Pete's
dragon a long time ago and I'm not gonna
lie I turned it off after the first five
minutes with the whimsical music and the
inspiring stairs and people saying lines
like see my daughter she knows a thing
or two but only if it's staring at her
in the face if you go through life only
seeing what's right in front of you
you're gonna miss out on a whole lot oh
my god stop stop stupid movie stop but a
lot of my friends were encouraging me to
give it a second chance so I decided to
put it on watch it all the way through
and yeah I'm glad they did Pete's dragon
truly does have some wonderful moments
in it some just okay moments in it and
yeah like I said before it's in pretty
bad moments in it but the bad moments
aren't as much as I thought and I'm
still kind of glad I saw it Pete is a
little boy whose parents are just so
gall-darn happy that they must die in
the next few seconds up right on cue and
he seems to come across and invisible
dragon that makes himself visible and
they form a friendship over the years
his time passes a ranger discovers him
takes him in and tries to find out where
he came from
Pete is of course a confused wild child
doesn't really remember the civilization
that he came from and naturally has
trouble fitting in but as time goes on
he does learn to lower his defenses and
eventually calm down and accept these
people as a family well that's going on
though his dragon named Elliot is
looking all through the forests and the
neighborhoods to find him and win Genoa
the brother-in-law of the Ranger saw the
dragon wants to hunt him down and blah
blah blah you know the drill
Pete says his dragon is real his new
family doesn't believe him and at the
very end he'll be revealed that he is
real or rather in the middle huh that's
interesting okay I'll give credit they
usually do this big reveal at the end
but they're doing it in the middle where
are they gonna go from here oh this
so yeah it seems like there's almost
three competing kids movies here one is
the really corny whimsical wishy-washy
stuff another is a very mature
slow-moving yet interesting story and
the last third is I don't know follow
that bird and it's just kind of one big
chase scene when we could be using this
time dedicated to the kid either
connecting more to the family or even
connecting more to Elliot
it's funny because as much as Pete and
Elliot are actually very enjoyable to
watch on their own the boy is very
believable and literally hopping from
place to place and looking truly lost
and the dragon while he looks fake it's
still very expressive and without saying
any words he still gets across a lot of
character nevertheless they surprisingly
don't have a ton of connection I guess
there's a hint at the beginning and a
hint at the end both strangely enough
involving looking at the North Star but
aside from that it's just him flying the
dragon around going whoo and that's
supposed to be a connection we've seen
that in a million films and it doesn't
really show how their personalities work
off each other seems like Pete asking
Elliot what he's looking at and Elliot
moaning while looking at the star and P
puts his head on his belly seems like
that really work and there's not much
dialogue but oddly enough most of the
movie they're separated so we don't
really get too much of a connection I
also have to admit I'm disappointed that
it's not left open to interpretation
whether or not the dragon is real I mean
they reveal very early on that the
hunters are looking for this dragon they
see him they shoot at him and like I
said in the middle of the movie the
family sees the dragon how much more
interesting would this be if nobody else
saw the dragon except the boy like
there's a scene where the dragon is
peeking through the window and the boy
is really liking the family and the
dragon feels really sad how much more
interesting would it be if that was left
open to the boy's imagination like he
feels like he's letting another life
down subconsciously this would be so
fascinating but nope he's just real and
people go after him with the guns and he
breathes fire at them and they just
scream and oh who gives a there's
other little things that get to me too
like Robert Redford is way too
all-knowing in this like when he sees
the dragon even though he tells
everybody he's seen it for years when he
actually sees it with his own eyes he
just goes magic and I'm thinking no he
should be like teary-eyed he should be
dropping to his knees like my god there
it is I've been vindicated characters
like the stepdad are completely
pointless you could have cut this
character out and not miss a thing
in fact you didn't have to have it his
brother that's going after the dragon
you go ahead that'd be the stepdad cuz
he's not really a super villain he's
just kind of a jerky guy that doesn't
understand
and at the end like yeah he's okay he
just didn't know that could have been
the father character it could have
connected to bringing their family
closer in fact all this talk about it's
not about what you see is about what you
feel it's about what you perceive and
all this stuff about faith and belief
why didn't they play more into that
maybe the adults can't see the dragon or
maybe adults that still have a little
bit of a childish mind or something and
Pete helps show them that childish mind
but some people are too far gone and
can't see it something like Polar
Express I don't know there's so much
more you could do with this but then
again I had to remind myself I'm saying
this about a remake of Pete's dragon
yeah
this film honestly I'm kind of impressed
with the okay movie that I got it's
different enough that doesn't feel like
it's just a rehash of the original but
it's also following in the vein just
enough a boy lost in the woods finds a
dragon has to get a new family this is
more the vein of remakes I'd like to see
Disney attempt except you know less
punch in the face whimsical music and
dialogue that sounds very Bridge to
Terabithia II so I don't know I guess it
is the best of the Disney live-action
remakes I've seen but given the Disney
live-action remakes that's not saying a
ton still I'm glad I saw it I'm glad I
saw it for the boy I'm glad I saw it for
some of the other actors I'm glad I saw
it for the drag and I'm glad I saw it
for the ideas they were starting to go
with they just never followed all the
way through with them nothing great but
okay enough for me to say check it out
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you